redness doesn't seem eager to talk about
it but he spent months in jail after
turning himself into police much of it
in an adult lock-up despite the fact he
was a minor
it was during that time that his family
desperately his mother mostly
desperately looked for legal counsel for
representation some people can get out
of jail in the end the family was
represented by a pair of lawyers called
lynnwood and john pierce
this came up out of nowhere we were not
expecting to have this conversation all
we're taken by surprise a little bit but
it's really interesting here's kyle
rittenhouse's description of what his
lawyers did to him
she get arrested what happens then once
i'm arrested i go to deputy juvenile
facility and i gotta i gotta say thank
you to them for their professionalism
and the jailers the the guards yeah at
deputy they're they had they were the
utmost professional people i've ever met
really
exactly
they were some of the most professional
people i've ever met
it was amazing like they treated me with
respect and
they didn't like talk down to you like
you've seen like in some videos they
just treated me like i was a human
how long were you there i was in jail
for 87 days and
this goes this follows in with lynn wood
who
lynnwood
was raising money on my behalf and he
held me in jail for 87 days disrespected
my wishes put me on media interviews
which i should never have done which he
said oh you're going to go talk to the
washington post which was not a good
idea along with john pierce they said i
was safer in jail
and set up at home with my family and
then after i'm built your lawyer said
that my lawyer said that john pierce and
lynn wood
87 days is a long time to be in jail it
was it was very long i lost a lot of
weight in there i i since then gained it
back
i know the feeling yeah
but 87 days of
not being with my family for defending
myself and being taken advantage to
being used for a cause by these
by john pearson lynnwood
trying to solicit not solicit trying to
raise money so they can take it for
their own benefit not trying to set me
free
so you think they could have raised the
money for bail faster but they didn't
um i believe it
i believe sometime in september
september 5th i want to say they had
over a million dollars and bail was set
and able to be posted in september so
they could have had me sign the waiver
for extradition and had me back in
wisconsin and i could have been bailed
out
by mid-september but they wanted to keep
me in jail until november 20th
what was that like
it was it was scary in jail like you had
to watch over yourself and
not a lot of people liked me in jail
until like
the funny thing is a lot of people
didn't like me in jail but they got to
hear like my story and they got to
understand me like
he's actually a really decent person i'm
not this person that the media painted
him out to be
and it it was scary but i was able to
make friends i'd say
acquaintance in jail and like play
spades card games with them
amazing so you're in jail for 87 days do
you have a sense of how your case is
being talked about in the outside world
um
not really when i'm in jail but once i
am bailed out john pierce said i was in
an unorganized militia which is just
blatantly false i didn't know what a
militia was wait your lawyer said you
weren't a militia john pierce said that
and it's blatantly false
i don't i didn't know what a militia was
until
after the fact until november like 25th
after i was watching some of the
interviews he did i was like i'm not in
a militia i don't know what that is
i'm sorry to laugh
and i was like
what the heck and i'm like no wonder
people are saying i'm in a militia it's
because he painted that narrative which
he should never have gone there
well yeah it's untrue exactly
were you surprised to so i haven't heard
you mention race at all in this
conversation you said you saw your
community on fire you wanted to help you
asked a business owner if you could help
were you surprised to see this framed as
a racial story
to be honest tucker this case has
nothing to do with race um it never had
anything to do with race it had to do
with the right to self-defense
what a sweet kid i think that comes
through loud and clear
playing hearts in jail
but he seems confused by the
descriptions
of this case as pertaining somehow to
race
what he didn't know when he was locked
away for 87 days is that the media
spurred on by democratic politicians
like joe biden immediately branded him a
white supremacist again the president
united states did that so sever several
members of congress
now during the trial one of the
prosecutors thomas binger particularly
loathsome character the government
lawyer mocked kyle written house for
putting out fires in kenosha
it's dishonorable to put out fires
apparently when blm sets them so we
asked kyle rittenhouse about that here's
what he said
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody like if they did this to me
imagine what they could have done to a
person of color who doesn't maybe have
the resources i do or is not widely
publicized like my case
what did you make of the president
states calling you a white supremacist
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement
that's not a small thing to be called
that
no it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
i mean why do you think and it's not
simply biden who said that it's a lot of
people on television have said that a
lot dozens of people have said that i'm
sorry to tell you in case you haven't
seen it
it's actually quite hysterical how
nobody can go back and look at the facts
of the case
he crossed state lines false
he's a white supremacist false none of
that is true
and the lies that they can just get away
with spreading is just sickening and
it's disgraced to this power to this
country
i couldn't agree more
so before this i mean you're 17 years
old so you're probably not you know
watching cable news all day or you know
deeply into politics or maybe you were
but did you know
how dishonest media coverage of events
could be
i i didn't i've never seen something
so polarizing in my life when it's just
it's obvious self-defense if you look at
the case you look at the facts no matter
what your opinion is or where you stand
this isn't a poli this wasn't a
political case it shouldn't have been a
political case it was made a political
case this had nothing to do with
race and the the ways people are
twisting this it's just sickening
i think a lot of people watching have
reached the same conclusion
and they would like to see you
you know help make this better by
holding some of these liars to account
do you plan to do that i have really
good lawyers who are taking care of that
right now
so
i'm hoping one day there will be some
there would be accountability for their
actions that they did okay so you're
you're intent on not you're not going to
let that go
like i said really good lawyers are
handling that yeah
um
so during the trial was there ever a
point where you thought despite the fact
you had all this video evidence on your
side bolstering your story did you ever
think you know i might go to jail for
the rest of my life
that was a thought i had every single
day until i got the not guilty verdict
really it was because i didn't we had it
i don't are you aware who john demetrios
is
yes yes so um joe owen selected my jury
which she did an amazing job but you
still have that gut that feeling in your
stomach and knots who are like what if
somebody snuck their way onto my jury to
convict me
so that was something that always went
through my head but i know where i stand
and i know i defended myself
were you surprised by the verdict i
wasn't i thought they came to the
correct verdict because
it wasn't kyle ridden house on trial in
wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial
and
if i was convicted
no one would be able
no one would ever be privileged to
defend their life against attackers
and thank god they came to the correct
verdict not guilty
so the media lies about the police
shooting of jacob
blake
a riot ensues young people from
throughout the area rushed to the riot
to set things on fire kyle rittenhouse
shows up to prevent things from being
burned to the ground to stop arson guess
whose side our leaders take
they call him a white supremacist they
slander him
watching him speak you realize just how
disgusting what they did to him is
just ahead he describes the months that
he spent in jail and the conditions
there hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else